Our next case.
Raffles v Wiggle House is famous and
memorable just about everyone who's ever
taken a common law contracts
class in the United States.
Will remember the case about
the two ships named pure lists,
whose names, if you think about
it, certainly weren't accurate.
The case comes from Britain in 1864
during the height of the British Raj in
India and the industrial
revolution in Britain.
The textile mills in northern England
needed a constant supply of raw materials.
And in 19 and an 1864 the American civil
war had shut down cotton exports from
the American south.
And so this case deals with a contract
for the sale of cotton shipped from
Bombay in India.
The defendant will call house agreed
to buy 125 bales of cotton from the
plaintiff raffles when it arrived in
Liverpool on the ship name to peerless.
Unfortunately there were two different
ships named peerless plying the route
between industrial Liverpool
and the capital of Britain's
largest largest colony
Winkle house.
Thought that they had agreed the cotton
would arrive on the peerless that sailed
from Bombay in October.
While Raffles thought they had agreed
on the pure lists that had sailed in
December.
You can see the October
peerless in this picture.
When the cotton actually arrived on the
December peerless wiggle house refused
to buy the cotton and so raffle sued.
It's likely that the underlying reason
for the dispute is that the two parties
were speculating on the price of cotton
and that the price of cotton increased
over the months in question.
Therefore,
the parties were very concerned about
when the ship carrying the cotton would
depart at the time has in
the merchant of Venice,
there could be no guarantee of exactly
when or even whether ships traveling
across the seas would arrive.
This opinion is an English case and
so it looks a bit different from the
American decisions we've read
from around the same time period.
You'll notice that reporters,
that the reporters summary or report of
the case begins with the pleadings of
each of the parties followed by a summary
of the arguments that each barrister
made with interjections by the judges.
The actual decision by the court or to
use the Latin phrase per curiam comes at
the very end and just says
that the defendants won.
The court was faced with the question
of whether there was a contract at all
given that the two parties had
had different understandings
of which ship would
carry the cotton.
The court said there was not a contract.
The key concept in the case is typically
called the meeting of the minds in
American contract law.
This case and British law generally
call it consensus odd item,
which is Latin for
agreement on the same thing.
The idea is that in order for
two parties to form a contract,
they must be thinking the same thing.
When they make it,
their minds must meet.
Otherwise there hasn't really been an
agreement and so there's nothing for the
law to enforce.
In this case,
the two parties misunderstood each other
because of the ambiguity of the term.
Peerless note that the misunderstanding
is different from mistake,
which we'll discuss later in the course.
Misunderstanding means that there was
never a contract in the first place
because there was no agreement.
Mistake on the other hand involves false
beliefs about aspects of what is being
traded and often means that the
contract is not void but voidable by the
mistaken party.
This ruling has concerned
contract scholars over the
years because courts have a
very hard time looking inside the heads
of the parties to see what they were
thinking when they made their contracts.
In his book,
the Common Law later Supreme Court justice
Oliver Wendell Holmes Jr pointed out
that if the ships had had different names
and one of the parties had simply got
the name wrong, they would have been
bound by this ship name on the contract.
Even though there had never in fact
been a meeting of the minds in his view
though for homes was
willing to go further.
He said the true ground of the decision
in Raffles was not that each party meant
a different thing from the other,
but that each said a different thing.
The plaintiff offered one thing.
The defendant expressed
his ascent to another.
The plaintiff and defendant
were essentially saying
different words that merely
sounded the same.
Frankly,
this seems to me like
philosophical sophistry to me
and most other commentators.
The party said the same thing I
said as a matter of objective, uh,
conduct.
It was just ambiguous.
Commentators have even pointed out
that the peerless doctrine may not be
necessary. Allan Farnsworth
argued that in cases like this,
neither party would be able to
sufficiently prove that the other had not
performed according to the contract and
so the contract would be unenforceable
anyway.
On a similar view,
we could say that there is insufficient
objective for a contract when the
objective manifestation is
ambiguous as it is here.
The doctrine about meeting of the minds
has been enshrined in section 20 of the
second restatement subsection one
deals with cases like fearless.
If there's an important ambiguous term
in the contract and neither party or each
party knows that it is ambiguous and the
other party is thinking of a different
meaning, then there is no mutual
assent and so there's no contract.
This can be thought of as the
peerless case. In another sense,
it's hard to find other examples of
pure symmetric misunderstandings.
Many commentators have tried to find
reasons why the buyer or the seller might
have been in fact in a better place
to avoid this misunderstanding.
These commentators have tried to
identify the party who in the words of
subsection one had a better quote,
reason to know the meaning attached by
the other unquote subsection two deals
with the asymmetric version of the
situation where one party knows or should
have known the others meaning but
not vice versa. In these cases,
the meaning attributed by the party
that didn't know is the meaning of the
contract and the contract is valid.
In other words,
if a party knows what the other
party thought the contract meant,
that party has to abide by what he or
she knew the other party was thinking.
So suppose the same scenario happened
as in Raffles v Winkle House,
except that wicked house knew that raffles
was thinking of the December peerless
under the second restatement. Is there
a contract and who would win the case?
Well,
the answer is a,
as section 20 subsection two of the
restatement tells us in an asymmetric
information case like this,
the party who knows the other's
interpretation is bound to it.
That means that wiggle house as much
as he would like it to be the October
peerless is bound to buy cotton
from the December peerless raffles,
we'll win the case
in this lecture.
We have seen that when two parties don't
understand key terms of a contract in
the same way,
there is no contract because there
has been no meeting of the minds.
But when the situation is
asymmetric with one party,
knowing the other's
interpretation and not vice versa,
both parties are bound to
the interpretation that
both of them are aware of.